he's daddy in this one did you just
describe John and everybody knows is
kind of dead isn't it he's kind of dad
this is so exciting we are on the set of
two other boys I've loved before they're
equal you've joined the cast how are you
feeling first of all you'll feel amazing
you actually hear noah screaming I did
hear no he's so loud of like on set by
the way it was like just in life in
general he's actually we've been friends
for eight years and have never worked
together on anything so this is our
first time actually working together on
something and then Ross Butler and I did
T Beach to Disney like five or six years
ago we haven't worked together since so
it's it's great you know it's a lot of
really wonderful very obviously very
talented people that love the story and
that's that's really where it begins
right it's I love it and was so drawn to
it initially because of its very
pedestrian very human oriented
conversational dialogue and and real
life stuff and challenges emotionally
that that people face an experience that
aren't really talked about and this is a
story that's like never really been
talked about before and it's it's so
diverse and it's it's really a it's a
people's film so you watch the first one
or two asleep and then you get cast in
this one do you feel pressure because of
how successful the first one was I think
that I recognized how beloved it is
child it's very helpful you know to talk
to different people that that are fans
of it have been
for a while came out what August of last
year yeah and the craze that took place
since it came out the fans of the book
before the film came out and the new
fans of the book and now the book series
after the film came out there's this
this gaggle of people this kind of a my
opinion kind of very generationally
defining era you know where this film is
concerned and obviously huge for Netflix
and and and great for the Y a kind of
Shawn or Fe will
I think that what pressure is concerned
I think it's really just more along the
lines of wanting to take care of the
material and take care of the character
take care of the thing that was kind of
an anomaly that people really love and
who are still loving and discovering is
there's gonna be a whole bunch of people
that didn't watch the first one that
watched the second you know did see the
second one come out oh I need to see the
first one and fall in love with it and
immediately can see the second one how
does John Ambrose come in and really
affect the story like where are we
picking up this sequel it's happens
pretty immediately after the first film
okay the book the book series is pretty
like story by story so that's no
surprise
Jonah Burroughs is you know if you've
read the books you know that he is he's
our jeans first love he was her first oh
my god I've got this I've got these
feelings I don't know what to do with
them let me just write let me write him
out in the letter that's how I can
express how I feel it's it it's safe it
was wonderful
obviously her intention wasn't for him
to ever read it but he does and reads it
late because of a forwarding address
thing because he moved away obviously
yeah very much a part of the story he
goes away and isn't in her life really
anymore even though it's like a cross
talent you know when you're a kid it's
not like 30 minutes away when you're not
driving is being a different shape yeah
so he comes in very coincidentally and
also just after he gets this this letter
you know rights are back and it's like
hey this is kind of insane like I can't
believe you know why am I getting this
letter now bah blah blah why are these
feelings what they are we've never
talked about them and then kind of
coincidentally comes into her life and
and it it throws her for a loop because
she's obviously just begun this
relationship with Peter you know and
then kind of poses the question like
what would have happened if he would
have gotten a letter earlier like so
there's definitely a love triangle
situation that's is what you're telling
me that is no surprise yeah like that is
exactly that's exactly what it is and
that's kind of a great foundation for
the synopsis of the film it's like what
do you do in Margene's position as well
specifically this guy I haven't seen him
forever
oh my god he's back in my life he
doesn't have a stutter anymore you know
everybody's growing up a little bit and
how do you explore that and I think that
one of the great reasons why we make art
in general is is to help people not feel
alone and what they're going through in
their life like you know you listen to a
song in it and it resonates in somewhere
you see a show and a theater you go to a
movie or watch a TV show you can relate
to a character like that that kind of
otherwise on tangible thing can happen
where good art is concerned and that's
we're telling this story maybe somebody
else is you know struggling with their
feelings in some way well let me ask you
this Peter Kavinsky that character
became such a team dream with a freshman
and she is dreamy in this one no sense
in AO is just a walking or walking
anything beautiful in my face love hey I
love him he only gets taller and and
gets more ripped and more charming yeah
you know he's he's amazing and that you
know that's that's Peter that's that's
that's that kind of goofy sweet charming
guy that you see in the first film
obviously there's things that happen in
the second film in the second book that
posed the challenge to Laura Jean
and then like I said coincidentally this
guy John Ambrose like unbeknownst to him
who was friends with Peter back in the
day his friends little R Gean and all of
like their Mutual's you know has no clue
that they're dating and whatnot he's
just yeah jeans arrogant they've got
feeling he's got feelings and and she
maybe has some too and what could this
be and then Peter is I love the Karen I
love your face every time that you bring
up Noah / Peter he's just awesome I just
adore him he's great Liz there's a real
bromance you know we only love each
other
there's a bromance oh god yeah we DIF
were over a long time and have been
comfortable around each other long time
but like actually get to work together
is something that's just yeah it's the
best
who was the dreamy or guy that I'm gonna
put you in the hot seat Oh Peter or John
Peter John I was actually just talking
Alana about this last night she if you
get a chance to talk to her at all
she'll tell you that she's very she's
very frustrated and confused for Laura
team there's all these things I mean
there's all these variables right that
you can't control
Peter if there's a yin to her yang like
Peter is the into Lauren's yang right
they there's the cliche that opposites
attract there's also the same one in the
same breath that likes attract yeah
large mean and and John Ambrose vibrate
on that same frequency and they could
kind of finish each other sentences and
are on the same page and he's got John
embers has this way this it's really old
soul you know and and understands people
a little bit more as kind of he's just
kind of been around even though he's the
same age as all these other kids who
he's been around
it seems and knows how to navigate
things knows how to take what would be
an uncomfortable or awkward situation
and immediately like just immediately
make it dissolve into something really
fun and beautiful or sweet or
light-hearted and I think that there's
something really charming about that a
very sweet about that and maybe even
kind of dreamy like John embers is some
I I just want to hug them yeah he's just
like the best he's the guy that you just
want to have around and Peter's the same
way in the sense that this kind of he's
the guy that you just want to live
vicariously through and then when you
have them in your life if you feel like
everything is just kind of more fun and
more exciting so we think he's dream
here I think maybe John Ambrose history
I mean you have to say John Ambrose all
right I do I have to yeah probably
John ever so true yeah does it feel
almost like a summer camp between you
guys because you've known him for eight
years and you said Ross Butler and then
obviously we have Lana who's yeah does
it feel like that between you guys and
how are you bonding outside of set we're
working a lot so there's like looks
pretty much like hey like I'm going to
bed I'll see you tomorrow at work got it
um otherwise that I I'm kind of a dad
like I like to hang I like to have
everybody in my place like I like to
cook I like to like play play board
games and video games and like watch
movies and Game of Thrones on Sunday
night it's that kind of thing so do you
posted this Instagram in the hair and
makeup trailer what is happening did
that one specific post it's actually it
it had been happening for probably 10
minutes before probably went on for like
10 minutes after that sue so Ross and
Nolan I have all been friends for a
while right and yeah and Lana was just
kind of in for a treat I think one day
where they put us all together like the
the joy the joy that Noah and I had we
were literally sitting we're sitting in
a restaurant together and and both heard
that Ross was joining the chasm
are you together yeah we did we found
out the city and it was the very I think
it was a very first day that we all were
working together on the film
Ross is kind of a walking boombox like
he walks around with this with this
massive speaker takes it everywhere he
goes music playing like all the time
kinda wouldn't expect it from them but
he yeah he's massive music fan and we
have a tendency of turning the hair and
makeup trailer into a nightclub like
you're dancing in there yeah it's a
whole it's it's an experience I wanna be
a part I want to see that I want to be a
good person yeah check out the foot it's
funny I've got posted it just brand I
was like oh my gosh like this is really
funny whatever whenever we're all
together yeah speaking of singing and
dancing yeah you are the master you are
a pro do we get to see John Ambrose
singing singing and dancing come on it's
funny I good I feel like I do a lot of
that and a lot of things that I work on
it's nice to work on a film where that's
not happening at all I'm just took a
from a person yeah maybe he like plays
an instrument for a second in this movie
but it's not what kind of it's nothing
well piano no I don't know I don't know
maybe it is piano and I'm actually
playing it was just really cool too
she goes down and that's their goal
there is to try to figure out how to
like find some closure and be good
people okay she apologizes he liked his
embarrassed that he couldn't really read
things correctly he thought he was
flirting he thought they were flirting
he was wrong it's tough it's really
tough scene but how much more dramatic
do you think this one is the first one
yeah I think significantly okay yeah I
think significantly because you know lar
gene is actually really going through
something very challenging very
difficult words the first one is like oh
like crap
kitty sent my letters out to all these
boys that I once had a crush on some of
them erm relationships one of them dated
my older sister one of them's gay wanted
you know all these things I think
there's the one guy that is far and away
and kind of removed and that guy happens
to be the first letter that she wrote
yeah and probably the most intense one
too because those feelings were so
palpable for her him coming back into
her life like really throws everything
for a little bit so it totally turns the
world upside down yeah yeah it's
beautiful and it's exciting but also
she's in a relationship and like trying
to work things out and figure things out
and going through some top of things
with Peter and like that I think that it
it poses a lot of questions and
everything also presents a lot of
challenges for her especially comparison
to the first of all do you and Noah have
a lot of scenes together all right now
John Ambrose and Peter don't have a ton
of a ton of stuff together because like
a lot of John Ambrose's things happen at
Bellevue if you've read the books like
they happen with large and specifically
there's the infamous tree house scene
that's very awkward where Peter and John
and Trevor Ross's character and Jen and
Chris and Lana for the first time lar
gene are all coming together like they
did when they were kids they haven't
done that in a long years and
everything's changed and everybody's
grown and
relationships of the whole nine so
there's there's a lot of really tricky
really tricky conversations that have to
happen in that and that scene a lot of
tricky dynamics between especially
between Peter and John Ambrose yeah so
it's interesting so Lana told ET she
really wanted this one scene to happen
where you guys go and you visit a
nursing home and there's some kissing in
the snow yeah does that happen this is
really sweet scene that happens kind of
near the end of the film large and John
Ambrose have thrown this ball you know
they're working at this retirement
facility and they've thrown this ball
for all of the residents they have this
typical like annual garden party that's
super tired and fluorescently lit
they're like nah we're gonna make this
we're gonna make this great like they
did this thing back in the day called
the star ball where everybody got
dressed up and kind of donned their best
dresses and the best suits and they all
got together and they danced and it was
beautiful and there's punch and
champagne and the whole nine and this is
just this is just on the heels of large
and and Peter breaking up for a second
and that there is a break up there well
I mean like I read the book we know you
would know that there's some challenges
and Johnny Bruce unfortunately suffers
from that but so there's a this is just
on the heels of the break-up right like
marching recognizes that she has
feelings for John Ambrose with whatever
capacity they are she has to kind of
explore them a little bit and John
Ambrose for lack of a better term kind
of loses his best life and like a 10
minutes band had like dances with Lara
Jean for the first time
walks outside and it's snowing in April
which is insane and like why this is
this is fate this is dreaming it's
beautiful and then one thing leads to
another and they and they like finally
kiss and you wonder what's gonna happen
and then Arjun recognizes what what that
is for her and that and and that her
feelings are what they are but she needs
to work things out with Peter and which
is tough it's challenging and I think
that all of these like very human
you know these very human nature very
instinctive things that we that we deal
with and that we think about all the
time and go through to be able to kind
of see this unfold in front of you in
real time is heartbreaking and also
really beautiful chai and she's she
handles that really well it's it's a lot
as an actress but specifically handles
this little thing very beautifully I
think people are gonna be happy
you said happy but are we gonna also
have tears if you love John Ambrose and
yeah probably well do you have a message
to the fans out there who just love
Peter and Lara Jean together I love
Peter and largely together you kidding
me I think that like this is kind of the
way that I like to put it everybody
needs a string to their kite right okay
one person in a relationship when it's
good and it's fun and exciting and
healthy and balanced one person is a
kite kind of all over the place and you
know fun the life of the party or what
have you and then there's the string and
everybody needs a string to their kite I
personally think that John Ambrose is a
string and needs a kite I think that
large gene is a string and needs a kite
whether or not these two strings might
actually come back together in their
life and become something more beautiful
than what they can work out as teenagers
and that's kind of up to the fans to
decide I think I think if those two
strings come together later in life and
become something more beautiful that
maybe wouldn't have worked out when they
were teenagers then that is a beautiful
thing it's very much like my story with
Eliot like I don't know that our
relationship would have worked out if we
dated when we were teenagers we're kids
I got don't maybe that would have been a
fun thing and a fling or what-have-you
and then we moved on and keep dating
other people but we ended up together
grown and settled more settled in our
lives and that's what's made it so
beautiful and balanced and real whether
or not Peter and Lara Jean end up
together and figure things out like
that's great wonderful if they do but
like I think that for the a the sake of
the story and the excitement of the
film's largely and Peter like need to be
together but I also think as a fan and
as a fan of the books
I think that Laura Jean and John Ambrose
like end up together I personally like I
think that Jenny does too Jenny Han the
author I think she does really she we
might have briefly talked about it at
one point in time but I think that if
Alan stones the air I think that John
Ambrose enlarging like end up together
they get married they have kids they
have a family but they do that I think
that that's what it is like started off
as puppy love never really explored
until like out in the snow for ten
minutes yeah and then it is what it is
for a second they both move on I think
they end up together I don't hate it
thank you so much I cannot wait to see
this movie to see what you do in this
role it's gonna be amazing I think it's
really special you know and and for
those of you guys at home maybe that are
fans of the film fans of the books we
love these characters we love this story
we love everything this universe that
Jenny Han has created is a really
beautiful one and I think a really
honest one which is why I wanted to be
involved in the first place and was so
excited to be involved I think that you
guys are gonna love it and excited to
hear what you think
[Music]